what is going on there citizens of the reject
nation greg here john tell the folks how you're
doing today guys i am better than ever before we
are going to watch today a trailer we haven't seen
like most of them we only saw the teaser a few
months ago this came out at comic con we were
focusing our attention on other things at
the time but this has been on our mind to
cover at least and we want to cover the show
when it actually releases or like we should
check out the trailer the lord of the rings rings
of power it's a three minute trailer i'm curious
i'm very very curious because it's usually
i liked but didn't quite knock it out of the
park for me yeah yeah this will be much more
substantial give us something to latch on to
so let's see what's going on leave a like
doesn't take too much work the work of man do it
we thought the war at last was ended like gladreal
i think so yeah hey our days of peace begin
is that wrong jewelry's be unending we thought
our light would never dim the skies are strange
not my frodo
the moment we feared
evil does not sleep evil dies tonight
beyond the darkness tempting shadow
to barriers all beneath the mountain
and i see
that him or oh [__] more like an orc
if the evil rising is left
unchecked it will take us off
ooh find the light and the
shadow will not find you
damn together we can survive
this i can't choose fight with me
each of us must decide who we shall be
trust between hammer and rock
yeah i got some nipple chills man
sexy saurons
wow trailer was
damn that was thick that was a lot of stuff that's
a lot of trailer yeah ball rod yes yes that's what
we really care about someone's gonna have to be
given the gand offline that's right man they're
gonna just have to do like a you know like a
more subtle delivery yeah you shall not pass
that was a great trailer that was beautiful
that felt insanely cinematic like the main
talk surrounding this leading up to it was
not really what's the show going to be about
but just how freaking expensive this show is and
it's all on screen it really does show you know
like the teaser it's like this is the only other
one i haven't even seen the other ones on my own
uh the first teaser that we saw really was like
yeah it looks good um cool it's middle earth it
looks like you know another fantasy show but it
didn't feel like there was something truly special
this feels like lord of the rings you know this
feels pure lord of the rings an actual prequel
show a series that feels like where you could
tell something truly fresh and warranted and and
looks better than the hobbit movies i know
there's a [__] for them hobbit movies i
don't know where they're coming from so i don't
mean to offend you this does look like it could
be better than that because it still has the
same aesthetic and peter jackson direction
influence all over it but it still looks like it's
doing its own thing and it's gonna definitely have
to breathe more and breathe better but the
scope and scale of it all and to actually
see galadriel's backstory because she is kind of
a stoic character you know a wise a wise wonder
yeah so to see this youthful side of her that
actually feels like a character who really
could get invested in an elf warrior who looks
apparently bad like the action looks really cool
it does and then sauron before he was you know
an all-seeing eye or like a super giant guy
fighting in the battles yeah that one who's just
a sexy lanky dude with a buzz cut yeah watch him
morph over time yeah you really get to get the
the presence and understanding because what was
he in the hobbit he was just uh the necromancer
what they referred to before like a big shadowy
yeah but before you learn who he actually is
before the movie reveals who he actually is
but uh here he's going to be an actual living
breathing character you can spend some actual
time with which i feel like could actually only
serve to further enhance the experience of the
films themselves yeah i would hope so that's been
my kind of trepidation with this series all along
especially with things like game of thrones i feel
like we've learned that like once you're straying
from like the really structured source material
things can go wrong sometimes we don't need an
origin on every specific character or villain
or whatever however looking at this offering
here this did get me really pulled in and excited
because a series is a perfect environment for lord
of the rings and yes tolkien has tons and tons of
auxiliary writings i'm sure they're borrowing from
for this history of middle earth and yeah it
really does look like a broad journey to the rise
of the situation that we meet at the beginning
of lord of the rings that is brewing and boiling
over and everything i feel like that could be an
actual interesting story to tell rather than just
like what else can we do with the lord of
the rings world so like i'm really pleased
not to be feeling cynical after seeing this
i guess because i know they've got the money
and you know they've got the budget to do the
effects and it does look beautiful and it does
look like they are yeah like you said taking
that jumping off point of what peter jackson
established aesthetically but also building on
it and i like that it seems like you're spending
time with the kingdom of men you're spending
time with the dwarves the elves you know the
other creatures orcs and things that inhabit
this it feels like a whole world here which is
encouraging to me because being not as much of a
fan of the hobbit it's like that aspect was kind
of crunched underneath the weight of all they
tried to pack onto that so this actually has me
very much anticipating a return to uh to middle
earth and i hope they knock it out of the park
because uh they have certainly invested in it all
righty well here we are lord of the rings bring us
how are you guys excited for this show well you
wanted to react to it here on the channel leave
your thoughts down below we'll cram in all the
books before then yes every piece of writing every
note every discarded page we're gonna be grand
experts experts make the time all right really in
leave your thoughts down below subscribe
click that bell let's end this with a patreon
rosa para happy belated birthday yes all
right we're gonna sing happy birthday to you
john's gonna sing in his deep voice and
i'm gonna sing in my really deep voice
yeah we'll do like a baritone harmony
ready three two one happy birthday to you
happy birthday to you